hi I'm ray I'm a tasty producer today
I'm going to be showing you how to make
my favorite Japanese recipes on the life
it's one of my favorite food growing up
you might remember this from eating a
feed episode where Andrew tried to make
chef more turkey chips recipe for Omer I
see this is a slightly different version
of the recipe I modified to be easier
and fun to make a home chef from kitchy
kitchy uses demi-glace sauce on top and
very soft omelette but the most common
style is rice seasoned with ketchup wrap
twisting on well you might think
seasoning rice with ketchup is a little
strange but ketchup it's popular
seasoning in Japan the most difficult
part of making or ISIL is making the
omelette the inside of the amla it's
almost like soft scrambled egg I wanted
to make easier way of making this and my
coworker Tony suggested hatching egg in
plastic run this is one of the first
video I made for tasty Japan I liked
making it this way because it's a little
easier and lighter than making a larger
complicated one like chef mo tokichi
I make my food whenever I don't feel
like making dinner or I can not find
anything in my refrigerator it's one of
my favorite Japanese dishes to eat some
of you might recognize this dish from
the tasty cook-off video it's not only
my favorite but it instantly becomes a
favorite of whoever tried that the
frying temperature is important i fry at
320 degrees to make sure the chicken
wings are fully cooked then I take the
wing style and rates the oil temperature
to 350 to make a crispy on the outside
I've made it hundreds of times because
my friends and co-workers
always ask me to the secret of the wings
it's a sauce the easy way to remember
it's the ratio two parts soy sauce one
part sugar sake and meeting it's easy to
adjust the amount whether you have to
make a smaller or bigger batch a big
difference from American fried chicken
age I coat them with potato starch
instead of flour it gives more crispness
to
it was my first competition and I won
but some people said I made wings
instead of fried chicken so it doesn't
come but wings also chicken so
technically two fried chicken I still
won there is a donut chain store called
mr. Dona in Japan one of their signature
donut it's there upon dating boo it's
Julia damn regular Donuts I wanted to
recreate their donut so I made this
video you might be surprised because I
used the tofu as one of my main
ingredients but don't worry it doesn't
taste like tofu at all
I added tofu to give more moisture and
body to the donuts Honda Dingell has
this cue ring shape so I shape the dough
into a small ball shape and stuck them
together on top of the parchment paper
when you fry it you can drop them into
oil with the parchment paper parchment
paper will separate naturally in the oil
once it comes off take it out from the
oil the technique helps the donut hold
the ring shape if you like mochi
you will definitely like these Donuts
they are quite different than American
Donuts but I like them because they are
not too sweet
but I'd love to hear what you think if
you make them tag me on the Instagram I
love seeing when the tasty audience make
sale recipes and these are really worth
the time
[Music]
I think a lot of people know ramen by
now but we also have another awesome
noodle dish called Oden wit only it's
made with flour water and salt it's
thicker and more tender it's usually
soft weeds warm soup or called soy sauce
based dipping sauce since it's only made
with such a simple ingredients
I remember we made dieudonné from
scratch at the summer camp we put flour
water and salt in a plastic bag and
kneaded the dough by stepping on them I
don't think that a summer camp in the
u.s. they are making good on noodles and
they are missing out there are a variety
of toppings but my favorite is
snickerdoodle or kitsune udon niku means
meat nickel udon it's usually served
with thinly sliced cooked meat on top
kitsune udon it's after which deep-fried
tofu skin called a blogger keeps a net
means Fox because the Guardian Fox seeds
of Shinto shrines are frequently brought
offerings of fried tofu
it's tota Roxy's enjoyed fried tofu
which is where tonight you don't got its
name from in a video we made a curry
flavor version which gives a nice spicy
kick to it
but a soup it's different in the west
and east side of Japan for a lot of
reasons some say it's because the
mineral content of the water and people
in Tokyo like a little stronger flavor
so if you buy instant noodle noodle they
make different versions in the East and
the West
it's a comfort food for me I always
crave it when the weather is colder or
when I feel under the weather
I made this video for April Fool's
basically you make small cream puffs and
stop a couple of demo means wasabi cream
puffs are not the Japanese guitar but I
see them everywhere in Japan and they
are one of my favorite dessert to eat
and make in Japanese we call them shoe
crema the tip aids when you heat up the
flour and water mixture you should mix
them very well until it's shaped like a
ball my trick to adjusting the amount of
eggs it's when the doll folds in a
triangle shape it's good to go
the dough is called pistachio and if you
fry them you can make churros I recently
taught Ryan and shame from unsoaked how
to make patashu once you pipe the doll
don't forget to brush some water on the
surface moisture helps your pastry puff
up in the oven whenever I make cream
puffs
I wait in front of the oven and watch
the pastry its puff up because I love
watching the transformation in the oven
the second tip aids when you are adding
eggs make sure to wait until the dough
is cool enough to touch so the egg won't
curdle or scramble when you are mixing
them with little cream puff is my
favorite dessert that my mom makes also
it's one of the first that are I learned
to bake cream puffs in Japan is usually
stuffed with custard cream and it's so
delicious so when I made a big one of my
unlucky core curds 8:01 with wasabi
which is a very spicy paste and not very
good dessert she didn't like it but
that's why I call them Russian Roulette
cream puffs
I make this cake a lot at home it's
quite easy and you don't need a cake
mode you just need a sheet pan
this cake is very moist so it's easy to
roll it up it's been 2 years and a half
since I started working for tasty
I was hired as a recipe developer to
launch tasty Japan but also learned how
to produce videos along the way I've
never made videos before but my mentor
Jody told me how to shoot and edit
videos very patiently
I love making tasty food videos because
it's just my hands and cooking I'm a shy
person and I've always been
self-conscious about my accent because
English is not my first language so when
our producer Spencer first asked me to
make mesmerizing Japanese data video
with my face and my voice I was very
hesitant
however after we published the video I
was encouraged by so many positive
comments and it made me realize that
your weaknesses can be your strengths
because it makes you different from the
others and that isn't a bad thing it's
what makes you unique and that's what
I've learned since coming to tasty and
sharing about my life and what I love
with all of you if you have passion to
share what you love there will always be
audience for it I'm really grateful for
all over your support and kind words
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
[Music]